earlier this week we reported about the
passing of Albert Avila he was a
Trailblazer for CCA for ccsd's Mariachis
program and a mentor to so many students
at Fremont Middle School well tonight
they are speaking out about the Legacy
he leaves behind
we might act the same like we used to
but it's not the same it will never be
the same
the Fremont Middle School Mariachi Azul
trying to fine tune their beat as they
continue to play with a broken heart
after the passing of their instructor
Albert Avila it really impacted my life
I will never forget him
if I didn't feel like like confident he
would boost me up and make sure I felt
confident the 39 year old passed away
after what his wife tells us was an
intestinal rupture in October she says
Avila helped launch the mariachi music
education program in Nevada
the program is the largest in the
country both students and staff telling
us their success was because of his hard
work everything I know is because of him
how to speak to kids how to approach
them
I feel like I carry a lot of what he is
as a teacher before his passing Avila
had learned the group had been invited
to perform at the Midwest clinic in
Chicago a National Music Conference
where his students would be able to show
off their skills in hopes of growing the
music program around the country these
are like little angels these students
are the Alberts angels and and somehow
we're sending them into a time and place
that Albert doesn't exist anymore and so
we need to make sure that his dream and
his message and his love of music and
Community reaches as many people as
possible
now the group is up against the clock to
raise thousands of dollars to continue
Avila's Legacy he was always the best
teacher ever and we will always remember
him
[Music]
needs to raise fifty thousand dollars to
make it to the music conference in
December a link to donate is on our
website 8newsnow.com